these webinars were prompted by a report
just released by c action about
accessing secondary markets for energy
efficiency
uh we're about to post a link to this in
the go to meeting chat window and i'd
really encourage all of our listeners to
go and check it out to learn more about
the role that secondary markets can and
have had in growing the energy
efficiency market
today's presentation is being brought to
you by the team for the yale center for
business and the environment's blueprint
for efficiency
which is in its sixth year providing
public webinars emphasizing the latest
trends and opportunities for energy
efficiency
each presentation is recorded and
available through the yale center for
business and the environment website
and the blueprint for efficiency itunes
u page
a link to download the slides from
today's presentation has also been
posted in the chat window
uh we're delighted to welcome today's
presenters
firstly adam zimmerman from craft 3
along with allison moy from self-help
credit union will be co-presenting the
craft 3 self-help deal
next bert hunter from the connecticut
green bank will be presenting
connecticut's cpace program
and finally we have
john byrne from the university of
delaware we'll be presenting delaware's
sustainable electric utility program
before we begin i have the pleasure of
introducing bruce schlein
director of corporate sustainability at
city and co-chair of the c action
financing solutions working group to
provide an overview of the work that fee
action is doing around the country to
encourage investment in energy
efficiency
finally i'd like to remind you that we
welcome any questions and we'll be
providing plenty of time to put those
questions to the speakers at the end of
this presentation so please put any
questions that you do have into the go
to meeting chat window
and with that i'll uh hand it over
great thank you very much michael and um
thanks to our uh colleagues and friends
at yale for for posting uh this webinar
i'm going to take a minute or two just
to introduce
uh
c action which i think many many of you
uh know or or participate in in some
capacity
uh c action is a network facilitated by
the department of energy and the us epa
of at least a couple hundred leaders and
professionals working to bring energy
efficiency to
scale you can see there there are eight
groups that comprise c action
the one that uh worked on
and helped advise on the paper that
that michael uh referred to and that
there will be case studies discussed
today is the financing solutions working
group
you can see on the
slide that describes that working group
the key barriers that
that were working to tackle
and the focus areas are also described
there with respect to
data access program design
financing tools
and the regulatory treatment of
financing
uh the working group um i'm fortunate to
be co-chairing together with my
colleague brian garcia of the
connecticut green bank
with great
facilitation from
usdoes johanna zetterberg and the us
epa's brian
and you can see there on the right hand
side of this slide we've got a great
group of colleagues that are
working together with us
in this working group
and then of course
exceptional
support and advice from
the lawrence berkeley national lab
what i'll do now is
turn uh the webinar over to
our colleagues at craft three and
self-help uh adam zimmerman and allison
moy
and uh and and and thank them uh and and
everyone who helped put this together
thanks
good morning everybody this is adam
zimmerman at crafts3 um
allison and i'll be telling you a little
bit about the transaction that we put
together uh mostly over the course of uh
now 2013
and closed at the very end of the year
so so i'm adam i i'm out in portland
oregon um
you can go to the next slide um
our uh organization is called craft
three we are you're what's known uh
in some circles as a community
development finance institution
um and we're we're charity we're
nonprofit we're a c3
for those curious the cdfi label comes
from
the us treasury department there's a
department within treasury that
provides support for organizations like
ours and self-help
we're
20 years old last year and we serve
oregon and washington
we have about
eight offices across two states
and our mission uh is very much about
investing in what um
used to be called the triple bottom line
but we look to make impacts on
uh the economic ecological and family
resilience of communities that we work
next slide
thanks adam so this is allison moy from
self-help i'm in the commercial lending
department here in our headquarters in
durham north carolina
similar to craft three we are a cdfi as
well uh we look a little bit different
from craft three in that we focus
nationally but
hone in on north carolina california dc
metro and chicago areas
we are slightly more complex in terms of
the number of organizations that we have
under our cdfi umbrella
we include two different credit unions
one that's state chartered another that
supposedly a non-profit ventures fund as
well as a non-profit advocacy arm that
works to combat predatory financial
practices across the nation
we've been working amongst these
different entities for about 30 years
with the mission of focusing on creating
economic opportunity through access to
credit for low and moderate income
communities
since our inception we've originated
about 6.4 billion in loans that includes
anything from a home loan to lower
moderate income family as well as
commercial real estate loans that
support the same communities
in the last five years we've been trying
to put a particular emphasis on our
green lending sector and this purchase
with craft three definitely falls within
that for us but in the green lending
sector alone in the last five years
we've originated about 140 million to
facilities that employ energy efficient
measures and have invested about 76
million specifically to renewable energy
producers
of varying sizes but mostly in the solar
arena so i'll turn it back over to adam
next slide to talk about craft 3's
particular program
thanks alison and and i'll go uh off
script a bit and just say that um uh
self-help is a
um
incredibly well respected organization
within our field of community
development finance i
i think allison's being modest they are
um a
a role model and you know i kind of
think of them as the granddaddy of
of cdfis and and those who are always
testing um new opportunities so when she
says they're a bit more complex and we
are they're way more complex
but that was great and so i the next few
slides are
designed to give you all a sense of why
we
built the portfolio and then and then
why we sold it so i will make two points
first which is as i mentioned earlier we
are we're mission-based non-profit that
does
a number of different uh financial
transactions types of financial
transactions and when we look at the
kind of transactions uh what we're going
to do we're we're focused on what makes
our communities more resilient and
and and
we very much looked at the energy
efficiency space as a way to reduce
overhead for
businesses and and homeowners in the
areas that we're working
uh and then the other piece is is to
create opportunity for
uh frankly construction trades and um
i know it may seem like distant history
to some of us now but when we started
doing this lending in 2009
uh we were in
at the cusp of the recession frankly um
or we're starting to wade deeper into it
so we were very much focused on how to
turn
energy efficiency retrofits into an
opportunity for small to medium-sized
contractors in our markets to
put people to work
and
so we we call that the the opportunity
climate economy the opportunity piece
being
ways for people to to build skills and
and
have a living with next slide
so um
this is the the basics on our loan
product i think i already mentioned
where we're after
jobs we're also after reduced carbon
impact our two states
are
incredibly focused um on
finding ways to reduce the
greenhouse gas impact of
um
of our region of the our of the country
um and then we're after what we call
inclusive credit so that means
allowing folks with lower credit scores
into the portfolio
we use on bill repayment both as a
method of repayment but also as a method
of underwriting so we look at people's
credits excuse me we look at their
credit scores and their
utility bill payment histories to
construct a
credit profile
and then we
have developed a way of shuttling
information back and forth
on uh people's payments with the
utilities that we work with
um the product specifications for the
portfolio that we sold
to self-help in large part the rate was
right around six percent
we started with longer terms up to 20
years
and reduce them to 15.
i will say about that that in oregon
washington we have a mild climate low
energy costs so
in order to push the
loan payments toward
the monthly savings or on an annualized
basis the monthly savings we really need
to stress out stretch out the
amortization
schedule and and that's important to
note because self-help was willing to
take a look at at assets that were
stretched out that that long um
uh we filed ucc on all of our loans we
we were in the past filing of
what was
in general a secondary view of trust
that became uh evident actually through
our work with self-help that that was
not a terribly important piece of um
the under right and and the asset
quality and we can certainly
talk more about that if people are
curious
and then the servicing is done through
the utility that provides the heat
we have a loan loss reserve that we have
built up that's available for losses and
that we look for
project types that
really minimize the cash flow impact
next cycles
so we work with uh utilities almost
exclusively we've got about three
percent of our loans that are off bill
and those are folks who originated on
bill
and then fell off uh in some cases
because they got in a tip with their
utility company not because they were a
bad credit um and that just happens
um
we're looking for
ways that um
we can offer inclusive credit and i'll
say just a little bit more about this
when we do a credit screening we first
look at the
utility payment history and we're really
looking for folks who are paying
relatively regularly over the course of
the 12-month period
and
we have a little matrix that
uses credit score uses a couple other
items and then looks at payment history
and we score each of those items and
if they come in below a certain score i
think it's four now uh we we've proved
someone and that means that they could
have a credit score as low as 590 but if
they're paying their bill regularly
uh we will make them alone
um and i think in general i mean on bill
is a long topic customers uh we find our
customers very much like it um they stay
with us performance has been good
um and uh we think that it reduces the
risk to the portfolio
across the board
but
we're only five years in now
and i think that
there's an opportunity to build data on
how on the support
portfolio performance
uh next slide
uh these are the four utilities that we
work with the three involved in the
transaction with south outboard
northwest natural pacific power and
portland general
next slide please
uh this is a bit about on bill if you're
curious um i think one of the important
things here is that we do not have
shutoff power um
my opinion is that that doesn't give us
a lot of leverage in terms of turning um
a marginal um
marginally performing loan into a
performing loan
by the time someone slides to the point
where they might be able to have shutoff
power i don't think they're recoverable
as an asset
in all of these relationships the
utility
retains payment priority
which basically means they get their
money first
what is owed to them
and
they'll only
the utilities will only collect the
payment
um once a month and then they remit that
to us to craft three once a month and in
the case of our relationship with
self-help we're performing the servicing
role and we collect the money from the
utilities we bulk it up and we send it
over to self-help with a reconciliation
reporting on a monthly basis
next slide
um so i i think i've i've hit most of
these in terms of inclusive credit i
think simplifying loan options for
customers is really an important piece
um i think that
a way for
um
on bill presents a way for customers to
pay
easily and quickly
our role uh
certainly in in our interaction with
self-help is to
present um
essentially a servicing mechanism for on
bill and push
the funds to uh
uh the secondary owner
and i think that's an interesting and
possibly uh
uh something that could be expanded um
we
craft three as an organization we don't
have a
brand of dog in the fight
we're not concerned that people see our
brand and want to buy other things from
us
and i think in some cases
investors don't really as long as the
asset qualities they're not terribly
interested in the customer knowing that
their loan is owned i think that varies
um the utilities and some of the local
partners very much want credit for
having delivered a a nice energy
efficiency
project and loan to consumers so i think
there's ways to move that around those
brand pieces around it and let
let credit accrue where it's most useful
i'm going to go ahead and go on to the
next slide
so this is a bit about the sale i think
the important piece here the important
pieces here are
the size
certainly the buyer who self-help will
talk in just a second um we only sold
loans with the uh with on bill as i
mentioned we had a few others
um
uh we had to um
go through
contractual update with the
participating utilities to make sure
that everybody
uh was on board with uh not only the
sale but the way that the loans were
being serviced on bill and that that
because it was new i think that um uh
strung out our process time wise a
little bit and that was that was really
the thing i think doing the deal itself
took
um about three months um all in uh maybe
a little bit more but then ironing out
this new arrangement with the utilities
took longer and i think that's just to
be expected they they generally move
pretty slow and they bring a a good
group of attorneys um which is which is
often helpful
they self-help had a little bit higher
minimum credit score but not much
we had a couple other items in there in
terms of loans that it didn't delink
with
and they were happy to accept either way
that we had done a security filing as i
mentioned in the ucc or adida trust on
loans that were
a bit older
and then we have
a loan loss reserve that we're carrying
and self-help can access that when a
loan becomes
150 days past due and then we have a
back-end
risk-sharing agreement for catastrophic
losses which
um oh we certainly don't expect next
slide
to allison
thanks adam this was a really exciting
opportunity for self-help to be able to
partner with craft craft3 who we view as
a really innovative cdfi that was trying
a lot of different kinds of products in
the energy efficiency space that we
hadn't ventured into yet
and for us this was an incredible
opportunity to
work with another partner to learn from
their experiences but also to build on
experiences that self-help had prior to
the recession on creating secondary
markets for low and moderate income
single-family mortgages so prior to the
recession self-help had worked in
conjunction with a couple of different
national partners to try to create that
secondary markets and working with craft
three to create a different kind of
secondary markets here for these energy
efficiency loans that they were
originating seemed like a great way to
build off of both our cdfi's
varied expertise
for us it was also a chance to really
push the envelope for self-help on our
green lending products as i mentioned
earlier we've extended a lot of loan
investment to renewable energy producers
as well as to commercial real estate
projects that involve energy efficiency
improvements but we haven't yet done
energy efficiency
to residential homes as craft 3 had
ventured into so it was a chance for us
to push our green sector
and to learn more through craft three
we were also really motivated from a
mission standpoint in helping craft
three
prove the efficacy of the on-bill
repayment model
as adam said it's still young and
there's still a lot of learnings to be
done to figure out if on-bill repayment
really does help enhance the performance
of borrowers and help default prevention
but part of our involvement in helping
creating the secondary markets for these
loans was to try to prove that the on
bill remodel the on bill repayment model
did have some credit efficacy and we're
hoping that the performance data that we
collect over time will continue to help
to build the case
as i mentioned before we are also
interested in learning a lot more about
how the characteristics of these energy
efficiency loans perform since they're
not ones that we originate ourselves but
are
embrace the opportunity to be able to
see over time how these loans perform
and as adam mentioned these are longer
term loans they range from 15 to 20
years
we've owned the portfolio now for about
a year
and one year is often a a tricky time
frame in the life of a 15 to 20 year
loan because you see some behavior but
it's still not a predictor of how things
will be over that long term but we're
excited to continue to collect
information and to see how things
progress and hopefully the next
several years of the loan terms will be
as good as the first year of owning
these loans has been
we also
wanted the opportunity through this
purchase to encourage some activities
that craft three was trying to build on
the ground in oregon through this
program adam didn't dive into it quite
as much when he was describing the
program but not only was this an attempt
to help
make energy costs more affordable to
residents of oregon but it was also done
in a way where the improvements were
trying to build a green workforce
locally in portland and that was a
workforce development piece of this that
we really wanted to be supportive of and
then probably last but not least for us
there was some real strong capital
deployment motivations in this sale and
we had merged and acquired a couple
different credit unions in the last
several years and had a significant
amount of deposits that we wanted to put
to good use
and didn't have the staffing capacity to
build up that deployment quickly in
direct lending so instead we looked to
find cdfi partners in the marketplace
who we could help by leveraging our
balance sheet strength to help them
further their mission so it was kind of
a win-win for both craft 3 and for
self-help because we were able to deploy
capital and craft 3 was able to recycle
funds to continue to grow the program
both in oregon and in other areas
so next slide
next slide please
i think as we step back and reflect and
take this moment as the papers were
being written and we were helping
lawrence berkeley national labs put the
case study together it was a chance to
really think about lessons learned from
this process i think the first and
foremost for both craft three and
self-help was the key that partnership
collaboration
and patience played in making this
transaction possible and also successful
so adam mentioned that this took a
little over a year
most of 2013 to
bring this transaction to fruition
and it involved not just the two of us
but also on the ground partners in
oregon
and as well as the utilities so with
that mix of players that we had never
dealt with before it was really helpful
to have the partnership and
collaboration with craft three to help
understand answer the questions that
self-help had about this product that we
weren't familiar with and also to
navigate all of the different utility
players that were at the table
and i would emphasize that that
partnership and collaboration isn't
isn't just relegated to the underwriting
and origination part of the transaction
it carries forward and is just as
critical once the transaction has been
closed
the questions and the um the the little
bumps in the road that come up after
we purchased the loans are
much more
readily navigable because of the great
working relationship that we have with
craft three
i think one of the big pieces
post-transaction that's really important
is the data and the processing between
our two organizations and i know that
sounds like a real catch-all phrase but
it really is very critical to
self-help from the perspective of an
investing purchaser
to ensure that all the information that
we get from craft three on a monthly
basis that gives us updates about how
the loan is how each of the 1200 loans
that we purchased are performing
where they are in terms of payment on
principal and interest
what their relationship is with utility
still from an on bill standpoint having
all of that information come to us in a
cohesive fashion that enables us as a
regulated investing entity to be able to
monitor the portfolio was really
critical and so that gets again to
underscore the need for a really
collaborative post-transaction
relationship i think one of the other
things that both craft3 and self-help
learned through the sale was
in the absence of long-term performance
data on unsecured loans which is how we
had to view these since they were often
fairly subordinated liens to the the
real estate um to the homes
it was important to think about what the
right credit enhancement tool would be
between the two organizations so as adam
mentioned there's a loan loss reserve
that craft self-help can have access to
as well as some other risk mitigants um
but we're hoping that over the course of
time we'll be able to document some of
the performance data on these particular
types of loans as self-help was doing
our underwriting of the purchase there
just wasn't a lot of real strong data
available in comparable loan products
and i think at the bottom line we're
both open to doing more and between our
two organizations and from self-help's
perspective we're also open to working
with other organizations who are doing
these kinds of
loans and craft three probably um
hit some of the bumps with our own
learning process and hopefully self-help
has we've gone down a good learning road
with craft three and are looking forward
to talking to others about their
products as well
so next slide
so if you have any questions about the
purchase or the transaction this is adam
and my contact information
and we'll be happy to answer questions
at the end of the webinar as well
so now i'm going to turn it over to bert
hunter
from the connecticut cpace program to
talk about his his details
hello can you uh can you hear me
hello
okay great thank you thank you allison
thanks emily for uh for running the uh
the deck here uh i'm delighted to be a
part of uh this webinar and just wanted
to commend the yale center
uh for the great work it does to keep
various stakeholders abreast so many key
issues that are driving the markets for
clean energy and sustainability
as well as our friends at the action
which
bruce mentioned we're involved with and
support
can
support their various activities
next slide please
so this is what we'll be going through
during this part of the webinar which is
focusing on the connecticut green bank
and its work
in driving energy efficiency and
renewable energy upgrades for commercial
industrial and multi-family properties
here in connecticut
so we'll give you some background brief
background on the green bank
some state energy contacts a little bit
about the cpas program
and then we'll talk about our portfolio
sale
and what we're up to now and some
lessons learned next next slide please
so the connecticut green bank was
created by public back 1180 it's the
successor to the connecticut clean
energy fund and
uh it marked the transition from rebates
and incentives to clean energy finance
in order to leverage public funds and in
that way catalyze private capital into
clean energy investments so we focus on
financing clean energy not clean tech so
we define clean energy quite broadly
here in connecticut
it
includes energy efficiency solar pv
alternative fuel vehicles and
infrastructure
and so forth we have a balance sheet
currently about 120 million and roughly
half of that is invested in financing
programs
cpas and our first and second solar
lease programs comprise about half of
that
and we're funded with a systems benefits
charge uh that generates about 30
million dollars a year plus some reggie
funds
and if you want to find out more
information just go to that url down the
bottom of the page there i'm sure these
flies are going to be made available
after uh we're done here next likely
so this is how we're organized uh
by various market sectors uh we have
statutory infrastructure which deals
with grid tied investments such as our
15 megawatt bridgeport fuel cell we've
got a wind project going up in coal
brook which is five megawatts our
residential sector where we have our
smart e-loans
uh does many things like what craft 3
was just talking about
we have our solar leaf
a solar loan product as well
which
we currently are not offering because
that graduated to the private sector
which we're quite proud of our
graduate and solar loan that that's
operated by cengage financials
and we also have our multi-family
efforts there in the
the sector with the dot around it dotted
line that's our commercial and
industrial sector which we do see tapes
and microgrids and some other activities
and then we have our institutional
sector which is where we have our lead
by example program that is in
collaboration with the
state department of energy
and environmental protection uh our mush
activities uh and and we're you see on
the left side we're really grounded in
state energy policy
uh the integrated resources plan
comprehensive energy strategy both of
those produced by deep
utilities with their conservation load
management plan and our own
comprehensive plan of the green bank so
all these
uh policy
uh
parameters are guiding us in what we do
and in my area i we bring in the
financial part we bring in the supply of
capital and the sectors deploy that
across the various markets next nicely
so here's the are the key challenges
that are driving clean energy policy in
connecticut
we have the highest energy costs for
electricity in the lower 48 states and a
very old and inefficient building stock
that we are trying to
make more efficient and we have a need
under policy for cleaner and cheaper
energy sources to try to diversify our
energy mix into renewable
sources and
uh from the storms that you i'm sure you
all know about in the northeast uh we've
got grid reliability issues we've had
outages that have lasted a considerable
period of time and so we're dealing with
that as well next slide please
so to kind of put a picture to
the energy costs
this shows
how energy costs line up across the
united states with the exception of the
mid-atlantic
click please
thank you
there you should see the mid-atlantic
takes quite a jump and if you click one
more time you'll see that new england
goes one step further and
uh and then connecticut is a few small
something we're not happy about but
that's something we have to deal with we
have commercial rates that are
just about 50 percent higher than the
national average and
industrial rates are about 85 percent
higher i mean it's just the it's just
these are staggering differences and
that's really drive home the need to uh
to be more energy efficient and save
save energy consumption whenever you can
next question
and so this is where uh c-pace comes in
it's a most of you probably know how
c-pace works we'll we'll dive into it
just briefly but it enables commercial
and industrial properties as well as
multi-family properties here in
connecticut and throughout the united
states actually
to access financing for energy upgrades
and pay those back via the property tax
bill
there is pace as well for residential
properties and the green bank reported
to the connecticut legislature this year
on our pace and submitted draft
legislation for our pace uh
so far we do not have our pace but
depending upon the legislative process
connecticut could have a statute it
place
at some point to enable our pace here
so but the key thing is to focus on as
far as commercial pays here in
connecticut is it provides this 100
percent
up front
low cost
around five to six percent right now for
up to 20 years
uh for financing your energy upgrades it
really does uh help the
energy improvements to be cash flow
positive in fact our statute requires us
to be cash flow causes and we'll talk
about that
shortly the owner repays it through the
property tax bill and the pace lien in
connecticut and in most other states
there might be one or two exceptions
is senior to mortgage indebtedness and
in our case senior to everything except
local property taxes
next slide please
so this is uh the public back 12-2 the
main key points uh from that statute
that gave the green bank the authority
in fact i'm going to start at the bottom
and work my way up i really think that
the bottom is the most important
because it really gave the the green
bank the
um
the authority to administer a statewide
program this does a lot of things for
one thing it makes it very clear how the
program should be run
and it focuses on one set of guidelines
but it is a totally open market
meaning that capital providers can come
in
contractors can access the market
property owners can access the market so
although we administer it
uh where it's open to all
uh the next to the last point
the municipalities have to opt in in
order to play and see pace and so they
have to pass
uh some debt it's the local level uh the
next point going in and reverse over it
requires cash flow positive to be
demonstrated that f i r the savings to
investment ratio has to be greater than
one
and uh the that's confirmed by an
outside consulting uh firm
uh we'll talk about very briefly and it
has to be permanently afflict to fix so
the lien stays with the property
the obligation to pay stays on the
property and so must the improvements
and
uh the second dot on the page there
requires the consent of the existing
mortgage lender this is uh part of our
statutory requirement we have to talk to
the lender that is on the property right
now but since it is a non-accelerating
lien
and when we enforce the lean due to
non-payment
uh
for
if we assign the lien and whoever is the
lien holder
forecloses on the property they can only
foreclose on what is due
or past due they cannot accelerate the
total obligation to the present time
and it's for commercial industrial
multi-family property next slide please
so if you're really interested in how
pace works
i would ask you to kind of consider this
slide
but generally
what happens is the property owner works
with the contractor they
apply to us we review it for whether it
conforms with sir and financial
underwriting considerations and assuming
that is all clear you go to the second
level where you get your project done
we provide the money out of our finance
funding warehouse
and in
the third
section down at the bottom there the
project is complete the
property owner starts to pay
the obligation back through the property
tax bill and we monitor energy savings
for at least five years thereafter next
likely
so to give you a sense of how much
progress the date we've had and their
progress has been considerable we are in
105 cities
uh across
connecticut there are 169 cities in
total but we have 85 percent of the
market so we've got the biggest markets
covered
more than 100 companies trained
a third of those have uh approved
projects
so um
and we have great success with our
mortgage lenders it says 25 mortgage
lenders have provided consent we're
actually up to 30. and we've done 70
million dollars worth of projects uh
with the most successful commercial pace
program in the nation uh 98 plus
projects have been approved 10 megawatts
of solar pv uh which is just incredible
just really bringing solar tv to
properties that otherwise wouldn't have
it and we sold 30 million dollars of
these uh projects off in securitization
to clean fund and we'll talk about that
uh very shortly so
um next slide please
here's one of our pace setters uh peter
corbett of in sports he installed energy
efficient lighting in a 252 kilowatt
solar pv system and invested a million
dollars and peter is going to save
his in sports facility
1.8 million dollars over the term next
slide please
so at the present time the green bank as
i said is funding all these projects
from our 40 million dollar warehouse
facility and that's part of the 120
million dollar balance sheet i
referenced earlier
but with projects coming to our website
daily we need to sell off
the completed projects to investors to
replenish the warehouse facility
next slide please
and this is how we did it back in
the summer of 2013 we organized the
portfolio sale this is the initial
portfolio with 11 projects 8 million
dollars on next slide please
we have to organize the
underwriting if you go next slide please
we organize the underwriting process uh
by
giving an offering notice laying out the
objectives of the sale instructions on
how to submit bids on this portfolio and
the schedule for accepting
bids
evaluating the proposals next slice
please
and closing the transaction with the
accepted bidder
we also wanted to be sure that uh
we made the bidders aware of risks
associated with these investments
they're unlisted they're not liquid
property owners may not pay and so forth
and we gave them access to a data
management platform with complete
information about all the projects you
can see the login page there next likely
and when you get into that information
in that database they would find a tear
sheet as we call it
summarizes the key details of the
project property owner location
uh the assessment
meaning the actual financing amount the
savings investment ratio debt service
coverage ratio
lean to value one of the value all these
metrics that we use to
underwrite the property next slightly
and here's a summary report of energy
savings produced by srs this is
where we determine the sir
next slide please i'll mention that that
s-i-r report is quite lengthy so this is
just the summary
and in the end the bidders have to
submit their proposals to us in a way we
can
standardize the proposal
across
all property
seems like powerpoint's restarting here
yep sorry about that that's okay
i'll wait for you to get back
i think we're on flight 21. uh oh i
don't know which 21 21 of mine but
not sure where that is in the deck there
there we go
keep going please
to i think we're down two more
and
there we go
and so this is the uh the result of uh
of that whole process we selected clean
fund and how we decided to structure
this deal was as a securitization so we
put all these
benefit assessments in a pool
we
established an inventor
that is a trustee
is responsible for managing the cash
flows that come in we have a servicer
that collects the cash but the trustee
is officially
responsible for getting the cash once
it's in the accounts to the appropriate
uh investors in this place in this case
clean fund as well as the green bank
clean fund has uh the
senior class a bonds representing 80 or
24 million in asset value and the green
bank retained the junior class b and c
funds 10 each for a combined six million
dollars in asset value
we uh so we stayed in the transaction to
credit and enhance it and by doing that
we were able to sell the portfolio at a
higher yield so
um all these transactions averaged a
yield of about
540 and change and we sold at about 5.95
so we suffered a loss on the sale
of the 80 of about 4
but uh keep in mind we didn't really
know where the market was when we
started this whole process so we
considered that a bit of a victory to
just have a slight uh discount for the
initial tranche and we're
much closer to uh to par right now since
our portfolio yields has gone have gone
up so uh we're in good shape the next
slide please or next
if you click once
and uh the transaction was a quote
watershed deal not my words but the
words of green tech media so we're quite
happy with the results
now you can look at that on greentech
media's website if you like next slide
please
so here we look at a progression of our
progress and you can see in the latest
uh six to seven months we have approved
transactions at a rate of three times
what we saw in the uh first year of the
program
uh we think that more contractors
particularly pv contractors are
recognizing that they can use 20 years
six percent financing to drive a ton of
business the commercial properties that
before
have been locked out of the market due
to the inability to advance these
improvements
next likely
so to cope with this growth we have
established the standard offers next
flight
uh and that is to invite public
private capital to partner with us we
will
work with private capital and credit
enhance their projects to a degree try
to encourage them into the marketplace
next likely
and we're also
making uh
let's see keep going one more
there we go um we're also making great
progress with an rfp for private capital
solutions uh we've uh we need a private
warehouse uh we just don't have enough
capacity on our green bank balance sheet
large as it is uh we're not 100
dedicated to see pace so we have to
provide uh capital to other programs um
so that's going quite well and we have
received a number of proposals for
financing facilities up from 50 to 200
million next likely
and i'm just going to gloss over these
this is the selection criteria you can
look at that when you get these slides
but it's just how we intend to evaluate
the proposals next slide please
and you can actually skip over that one
and we'll get to some of the lessons
learned
so the key one the key lesson we learned
is private capital thankfully likes this
asset class that we were able to move uh
these uh these investments
and uh judging from the response we've
had from our rsp there there's a
considerable interest now
in this asset class so the green bank is
actually
succeeding at crowding in funds
by taking early risk and aggregating
but at the same time uh to be successful
here we think you really have to think
holistically and strategically as we say
because there are just a lot of moving
parts
in this this puzzle called energy
efficiency
selling a portfolio in advance was a big
challenge for us it's going to be a
little bit uh easier now than a
considerable portfolio of transactions
that were moving in the market uh so
we've demonstrated that we can uh
originate these transactions and that
there is a marketplace that is uh really
ready to scale up uh this uh this market
in energy efficiency we also learned
that pricing isn't everything i think
that's a key lesson uh transaction
friction can kill a deal it's more
important i think in the end to have
partners that you can work with and
realize that this is a market that's uh
dynamic and it's evolving we've got
many different lenders and investors
coming in the ratings methodology
uh is evolving for for when we hope to
be a part of a rated transaction in
securitization
and there's a constant feedback loop uh
everyone's getting smarter and better at
this and and we think we're part of it
and doing our bit to uh to prove that
this can uh this can work and be
successful so that's the end of the
presentation next slide we'll have my
contact details and happy to talk to any
of you about this uh
anymore
after the presentation or take two
questions later okay
okay i think
we'll go to the uh this is john byrne
and i'm with the foundation for
renewable energy and environment a 501c3
created to develop programs that
particularly involve
structured financing and i will
go over a couple of cases in delaware
and pennsylvania
um very thankful to emily and michael
bruce the sea action network and yale
center for
uh business and the environment for this
opportunity
next slide please
i'm going to cover the use of the bond
market for financing that's already been
covered with a bit with bert's
presentation but i'm going to focus on a
different segment of that market
and so i thought i would begin with why
one would look for
a look to this market and there are
several reasons i thought i would just
call out a few uh costs
um debt financing through the bond
market is
almost always going to be the uh the
cheapest option if you can put it all
together
it certainly has sophisticated investors
that know how to
analyze
our products and uh can certainly
provide in this way
a substantial we have not found any
difficulty in terms of size or scale
for this kind of activity so we think
the the market is a really excellent
market for the focus that we have which
is
really in that second bullet about
community governance trying to give
both the geographical community cities
counties states
the opportunity to make choices about
the underlying infrastructure in the
public sphere
and then also
those
communities defined by function or
even virtual communities that want to
for example hospital groups or
university groups that want to specify
goals for themselves and then want to
finance
the
realization of those goals
in a cost-effective manner so that's
really been our focus as you can see
these are the
indicative borrowing rates from a
program we're now offering in
pennsylvania
it's
our our approach is pooled financing
that involves a serialized
structure so you can see what our
borrowing rates are for the first year
of a
say a 15-year borrowing and then you can
see the fifth and the tenth year and you
could look at an a-rated and see that
it's really uh very handsome in terms of
of borrowing
rates the other thing that
really compelled us here
i've used the the notion of
grandchildren i'm a grandparent
grandchildren mean a lot these days
we have a significant problem
that we need to resolve
best estimates out there is that we need
to cut fossil
fuel use by more than 50 percent in the
next 20 years
and uh to do that we have to go much
faster and try and find ways to give
people
choices that go beyond what
is currently provided in the more
incremental elements of policy on this
issue so those are three reasons why
we felt that the bond market was a
really good idea
but there are
also problems with going to the bond
market next question
our next slide
this is a sophisticated market but it
also means that you've got a great deal
of expertise you need to pull together
to make this work and
another key challenge is that there's a
great deal of documentation that's
required in order to in order for you to
go to the market from
early on letters of interest all the way
through
different kinds of
investment grade audits that might be
performed guaranteed savings agreements
uh monitoring and verification um
a related problem is that the financing
itself in order to structure this
particularly to involve several
participants is is complex
and
this is our simple graph of a uh
of a bond financing you can see if
you're the participant in that red box
down there
you'll be signing up for a guaranteed
savings agreement
that is going to pledge a rate of
savings i'll get into this that will be
greater than
the financing you're going to use your
own appropriation
um
source as a way to pledge payment to the
the issue of the bond
there will be a program agreement that
will govern all of the moving parts of
all of this and then
you're off to trustees and bondholders
and
it's it's quite difficult
as a as an approach but it has as i'll
show you in a moment some great
dividends
for some um over time esco has become a
four-letter word uh energy service
companies uh
try to balance many many things and
i think it is not an easy task that the
that the sector has but there is
pushback particularly in the public and
non-profit sector
uh as i will try to show you we try to
address that problem in a particular way
and the last part that i think is very
important this is a process that will
take six to eight months to to go to
market there are a lot of steps and a
lot of moving parts and sometimes
participants
particularly moderate scale cities and
counties school districts i'll get into
all of this in a moment can find
themselves sort of overwhelmed by
uh the process so that's uh
that's one of i think
the reasons uh
that we need to think about how better
to do this this kind of
financing opportunity i'm going to try
and address ways in which we at least
have felt that we
could overcome a number of the problems
that are presented here
on this slide let me go to the next
slide now
when
it works and we were able to do this in
the case of the delaware sustainable
energy utility
uh also a 501c3
that i helped
develop and
co-chair the board
through this financing that i'm about
now to briefly
indicate to you we were able to
sell a bond issuance
involving eight
participants
six
public agencies and two non-profits
and
we involve six
contracting companies many of these
companies are well known i'm sure to
a number of you from
johnson controls in the resco to train
and ameresco honeywell so
we put together this uh
this investment we were fortunate to go
to the market and
sell our first ever
issuance of debt for this purpose
with premiums
we
purposely designed the program to have
a long
payback period we went after the deep
retrofit not simply the
sort of uh
early paybacks and lighting and
uh
motors and controls and that kind of
thing
so we were out as an average payback of
14 years the bond itself was a 20-year
series
our effective borrowing rate was
just about 3.7 percent over that
entire
issuance
the
bond had was sold back in 2011 and you
now have both construction
period performance and post-construction
performance
and both in the period of construction
and afterwards
in every case
for all eight participants the
uh performance has exceeded the
guarantee
so the result of all of this has been a
very good thing for
the participants in delaware the
delaware scu
sustainable energy utility is very
happy with this model
and
was able to i should mention was able to
do all of this without
any contribution by the seo into the
deal itself that is the
the pledge of payment by appropriation
and the backing that was there from the
guarantees the guaranteed savings
agreements was sufficient for this
particular financing
to take place
if we go to the next
slide the overall
results of this particular transaction
at the delaware level
there is a pledge of payment if
necessary
uh from the energy service companies of
up to 148 million
uh the
uh all in cost including all debt
service transaction costs
monitoring and verification
costs and so on all of that in is 110
million creating a
a
surplus of about 38 million dollars on
the deal
if you this
involved only four percent of the
of the floor area of
the public sector in the state of
delaware if you were to apply this
similar
uh percentage at the national level this
is not for federal this is non-federal
properties
this is a financing that would be on the
scale of 25 billion dollars
and i bring that up because this is
since it's only four percent of floor
area this is something that
if it was done properly is something
that could be done on a regular basis
and these kinds of savings and
job creation could be part of a of an
ongoing
process
a last step that i'd like to just
mention in terms of the benefits that
come from this kind of approach
the um the savings that we're talking
about are not estimated savings that
sometimes occur
um in different rebate programs for
example this is uh these are monitored
throughout the term of the
of the debt and so a monitoring and
verification process is there to make
sure
uh that the savings are actualized
i'll get into what happens to cure it we
have an improved program in pennsylvania
that i'd like to
focus on for that purpose in just a
moment
um again it did not require ratepayer or
taxpayer support for this to occur this
was a self-financing
approach and in this sense
represents i think a companion to what
you've already heard on the panel today
of ways to go about
and hopefully speeding up the process of
investment in
uh sustainable energy
so that's the uh that's the delaware
deal and on the strength of that deal
uh next slide please we um
organized a new set of programs
in other states in the u.s and the one
that i'm going to just briefly go
through is
our sustainable energy finance program
in
pennsylvania which is
offered
with the pennsylvania treasury
the treasury is a an investor in the
program and is helping us to
market
the program
the
uh the key things that we learned from
the delaware deal to try and do this
better
are to make sure that there's a very
careful pre-qualification
of companies so that they can meet the
stiff standards of a guaranteed savings
agreement that we require the guaranteed
savings agreement uh
spells out the monitoring and
verification
plan in great detail and because of the
way that we
create this uh this guarantee the cure
is on the side of the companies they
must either deliver the dollar savings
that are
pledged in the agreement or they must
cure by
installation of additional equipment on
their own dime or
working with the
with the entities to
make sure that a better use of the
building for example management
improvements that could
make that
that occur
we guarantee only the energy and water
savings so that operational savings
deferred maintenance and so on are a
bonus that is
we've created a program where the the
guarantee
in terms of its actual impact on the
participant is conservative
we provide a trusted advisor function
the free team has legal financial uh
technical energy specialists that work
throughout the negotiations of the deal
and we offer a post-construction uh
support up to uh three years
so these were some of the important
things that we learned standardizing the
documentation also it was critical in
delaware and i think we've done an even
better job since then
and particularly in pennsylvania i think
we have a very good
set of documents and if you want to see
the documents you can see at the bottom
of the
slide where the
website is all of the documentation is
there
if you'd like to take a look
a second major uh
lesson was
in the next slide was to widen the
participant base
in the case of
delaware we dealt with
mainly state agencies
it's become quite clear
working in other jurisdictions that
we need to widen who can participate in
this and that also means that we have to
have the kind of expertise needed for
uh the um
different kinds of uh entities to
participate so
this is the uh the range of participants
that we are now marketing to in
pennsylvania
next slide please
we also
make sure that we can customize the
measures for the individual participant
that is a really key
factor there is no one-size-fits-all
i think many of you know that
a couple of measures such as lighting
have often been
used as the basis for these kinds of
financings but it typically is the case
that
uh these public and non-profit
participants are really looking for a
series of measures that can be
implemented
um
and uh through that implementation
process that a more comprehensive
approach to their energy uh requirements
can be had so
we basically include all of the standard
conservation measures but we also
include distributed generation on site
uh we have worked in a variety of
different renewable energy sources
including
solar we
have also worked on a variety of options
we're currently looking at a microgrid
in one of our
project opportunities and
all of this with the key requirement
that
whatever the investment is that it can
create a stream of energy and water bill
savings sufficient to fully
finance the investment
finally a major thing that we learned
out of all of this next slide please
monitoring your verification a lot of
times unless you are talking about a
large
entity that has staff on hand to be able
to handle this
m v can kind of be part of that
participant in headlight syndrome
folks don't find it easy to to
understand or
to utilize to their own benefits so we
have done two things here
first of all the monitoring and
verification process that's in our
documentation
uh is diagnostic
it provides advance indication to the
both the participant and the company
that has signed the guaranteed savings
agreement whether the guarantee is going
to be met and it provides the basis for
cures
to then be developed over the course of
the year in order to assure
uh that the
that the guarantee is met
rather than arguing over fine details of
uh
how to measure building performance and
so on we have removed that
uh particular problem in the past with
mmv instead the program itself sets the
uh
a schedule of energy and water prices
over the 20-year period
the program
through the advice of the free team sets
it conservatively
and that price uh vector is then
multiplied by the
physical unit
uh savings that
are provided by the
uh the participating uh contractors and
uh that then defines for each and every
year what the dollar savings must be
and
the question now is only how can we make
sure that we meet that most cost
effectively we use all the standard
m v protocol but i want to emphasize
that
the approach that we take here
essentially removes
what has been passed practice of arguing
over
finer details on methodology and instead
simply diagnoses what needs to be done
because the free team is there as part
of the both the negotiation process and
the post-construction process
we are able to turn this particular item
away from what has been
not necessarily positive experience for
some uh we've now been able to turn this
into a step that actually
is a positive part of a transaction of
this kind
all right the next two slides my final
two slides just briefly go through the
process by which
one
participates in a program like this this
is the
the
pensef particular eight-step process we
we obtain a letter of interest from
participants and we gather a sufficient
number of letters to
then produce education days because
pennsylvania is a large state we
do these educational efforts in
multiple locations
where we go through the financing in
detail and
the
participants can ask
questions and then we break down and
work with them afterwards
on how to get
a project development process started
for them
we assist them throughout all of the
steps we
help them to get the kind of data that
will be needed for
a pre-contract off audit that we offer
in the process this is no cost to the
to the participant
and
we have a fairly seamless way in which
billing and
other kinds of data that's needed uh
come to the
the escos that are pre-qualified
and we then
use that pre-contract audit to give
participants an idea of what kind of
project or project they might want to
think about
if they next slide please if they like
the
what they see
we move to a next step which is to then
have an investment grade audit done the
investment grade audit must deliver at
least 90 percent
of the
savings identified in the pre-contract
audit uh this is to prevent gaming
of
participants in this particular process
we then move uh with the participants
through that iga the investment grade
audit if they
uh find enough in there that they want
to
develop into what we call a project we
then
begin to package that project into a
guaranteed savings agreement again the
documentation was all standardized all
participants
all participating companies
use the same documents for this purpose
and we back in that guaranteed savings
agreement with a detailed
um
monitoring and verification
plan
next step is then for the
the
participant to accept the proposal
spells out the guarantee they get to
indicate they get to choose
and we customize we give them different
analytics on
options they might have so that they can
look at what their uh debt payments
against uh savings would look like and
if they want to front end stuff they can
do that if they want to back in we can
do that if they want levelize that
service
we can do that um
at that point we then move to the
performance of the retro fit work
this does include on-site generation we
have done renewable energy projects as
part of this as well
and then
as i mentioned we then stay with the
process after construction to make sure
that
the monitoring and verification
plans actually show to the satisfaction
of the participants that they are
realizing the dollar savings not simply
physical unit savings uh that they uh
had anticipated
um and that's really the basics of uh of
the
program
uh i've included i just mentioned i've
included
i won't go into them but some
additional information on the new effort
that we're working on which is to now
create what we
regard as solar city platforms and which
investment for example in
solar technology can take place on a
citywide basis and we've just completed
an analysis for
six cities
uh new york london
amsterdam munich tokyo and seoul to show
how
you can combine policy technology
financing we did all of this as bond
financing
and so i think there's a lot of exciting
opportunities coming up on this kind of
scale and i just wanted to
let you know about that particular item
and i think that's all that i have i'm
trying to go quickly so that we don't
chew up the entire time of the
webinar for presentations thank you very
much
hi this is emily um and i'm hoping that
you can hear me i know that the yale
team who's going to be moderating our q
a has been having some technical
difficulties so yale if you you can hear
me
we actually can't hear you hi hi emily
can you hear me now emily i can this is
birch hunter i can hear you
emily can you hear me now yes there you
are michael hi
myself uh okay so we had we've had some
good questions from the uh the audience
um i'll start off with adam and alison
uh we've had a few questions from
patrick and carol
uh and a couple of others uh really
about what's in it for the utilities to
participate in on bill financing
are they incentivized are they
charged a fee
and if not how would um you know being
charged
or
charging a fee for that process affect
the economics of on bill financing
uh
so i'll take that quickly this is adam
the um we we do pay the utilities uh
monthly fee craft three pays the
utilities a monthly fee for the cost of
providing on bill servicing and it's
it's it's quite low
um
uh we've been recently talking with them
about
um what they should be charging and and
it's it's a good healthy negotiation and
i think they're they believe that
uh this has been a benefit to their
customers they see happy customers
um
and and so they um they're working with
us on the fee
uh interestingly in oregon on bill
repayment
is uh by the ious is more or less
required by law by state law
so when we started this the utilities
were
compelled to have a conversation with
ourselves uh the department of oregon
department of energy and the energy
trust of oregon which is a strong
partner in this and has been
um
helping uh the conversations with the
utilities
from the beginning and now plays a more
integral role in terms of contracting
um
i would say though that in the last six
months
uh conversations between craft three
energy trust and the participating
utilities have turned more to a
voluntary
uh um
uh
perspective so we are now talking with
them about
uh expanding on bill lending programs uh
to their customers and they they are
coming to us and asking us to help them
develop that feature um both us and at
the energy trust of oregon so that has
been very interesting i think that is
proof
uh that
they
um
view this as a positive feature
great that that makes a lot of sense um
okay so the next question is from roger
and it's for birth
and the question is really around uh the
role that sea pace um specifically for
solar
plays and how it competes with um other
private developers like solarcity do you
see
um these two financing mechanisms as
complementing each other or really in
competition
uh thanks for the question
i see them as totally complimentary
excuse me and the reason is because um
it really comes to the property owner's
preference if they want to own the
system themselves and take the tax
credits and depreciation they're able to
do to monetize those tax credits and
depreciation then
uh
they are able to do so through a
financing
of the
pv system
on the other hand if they want to work
with
solar city or any other third party
owner
we can secure
and we have made many presentations on
this we can secure the repayment of the
ppa through the cpas mechanism so we're
able to
do both so we see them as perfectly
complementary and and
in that innovation that we pioneered
here has actually been adopted in
california i believe as of january 1.
great thanks doug uh okay the next
question is
for john and it comes from james
um
with the guaranteed savings agreement
how are changes in personnel and weather
impacts adjusted for in the savings
results analysis
yeah that's uh thank you that's very
good question the the guaranteed same
needs agreement
has
within it
a uh an ability to adjust for example on
the baseline if the
change in personnel or change in
function of a facility
occurs then there is a process that's
spelled out in the giza
of uh how do we
define uh the baseline for that that
purpose at the end of the day the
financing must still
uh generate savings that are uh greater
than
uh the cost of financing and
so that baseline adjustment is part of a
process of trying to recognize what can
happen
over time and but to do so in such a way
that you
retain
uh the requirement of
of the savings in effect being greater
than
um the payment that
that the participant must make
to the bondholders
great
okay so we've got uh another couple of
questions for adam and allison these
come from steve and carol
really around how you would go about
setting up a non-bill financing program
in a new jurisdiction or with a new
utility
what approach would you take what sort
of conditions need to be in place for
that to be successful
um
well
i i would
i would first of all say that our
organization craft three we're a finance
institution and we um we speak uh sort
of a novice utility speak
we have been very lucky
in oregon especially to have
the energy trust of oregon which is a
an organization that was created
by state law to work with utilities on
conservation and renewable energy to
work with the utilities and us to
set up a number of these programs so um
from our perspective as a as a loan
originator i think it's really important
to
uh
um
excuse me i'm sorry
i it's very important as a loan
originator to have a partner that works
uh in in utility land and can help
translate some of the more complex
questions about regulations so i i would
i would look for someone at the state
department of energy in the states that
you work or if you're lucky enough to
have um
one of the third party organizations
in in states like vermont and in
wisconsin that would be very helpful
other than that i think it's
about crafting agreements that are very
clear
in terms of
risk mitigation and protection for the
utilities so our agreements
with utilities and energy trust
spell out very carefully what we
um what we do with their customers and
what they are not obligated to worry
about when in terms of loan losses and i
think that's a huge piece
or defaults
or delinquencies that's a huge piece of
what we do because ultimately they just
want to process the payments and deliver
their
customers a service
okay thanks for that uh okay so the next
question is from steve for john
and he asks how delaware's seu projects
have actually performed so far
and he was wondering specifically if
escos have been forced to step in
financially to meet projected financial
performance in many cases
so john did you uh did you get that
question
okay looks like we may have lost john
we'll uh we'll move on to the next uh
question
um
i'm sorry i
i muted and did not mute
so quickly uh yeah on the delaware
sustainable energy utility website the
energize delaware you can find the
latest report on performance um so you
can see what did happen but no esco at
this point has been under guarantee all
individual projects and all projects
together are over the uh
the guarantee so the uh
and our experience working elsewhere we
have looked at
uh these programs and and offered these
programs in other jurisdictions
um it is certainly the rare event that
fiesco fails to meet the
uh the obligation partly because the way
in which we structure the financing uh
the estimation
that's coming in is conservative against
what will be actual performance and
so i think uh
so far so good um on the broader points
the delaware seo offers not only the
bond financing but
other uh approaches where for example
loans where there is some cases that
there can be some
um
failing on that side but uh for the most
part i think these programs as i think
all of my colleagues on the panel have
indicated these are very high performing
very high percentage
uh and that's part of the reason why the
market likes
great thanks for that uh i guess we'll
do uh two really quick and last
questions because we are out of time
uh firstly melissa asks uh both either
adam or allison
how property sales are handled
do property owners have to pay for the
remaining loan balance in full prior to
sale or does it transfer with the
property
i'm sorry allison i'll just take that
one again because we deal with that
daily um uh so we subordinate um uh for
refinances in most cases uh when the
property is sold we we have a note on
title um uh in terms of the ucc so we
look to the owner to to pay off
if they don't pay off or cannot pay off
or it's a hardship of some sort we work
with them and like i said i think
earlier we have a small percentage of
our portfolio that is
serviced via ach and not on bill some in
some cases those are folks who
um uh uh had to sell it and and and
under a hardship scenario but in most
cases they are paying us off at sale or
we simply won't clear
our ucc or or deed of trust off the
title and that
messes up the the transaction presuming
it's not a cash transaction
and this is allison i think what's been
interesting for us to see over the last
year perhaps an obvious uh
piece but the the shifts in this book
have really um trended with the overall
residential markets and so we've seen a
lot of prepayments actually happening
and homeowners have been able to
refinance fairly quickly so for us it'll
be interesting to see with the book that
remains how that continues to perform
since we had such a high rate of
prepayment at the beginning of this
thanks guys uh so we are out of time
this is going to be the last question um
but thank you uh everyone giving us so
many uh so many good questions so this
one comes from skye and john and it's
for john
um and you're both wondering a little
bit about a little bit more detail about
the free
um
process so the the post construction
advisory service
what exactly that service entails
right
when construction concludes sometimes
participants can find themselves
still a bit
in difficulty on understanding what
their legal
rights are and how to make sure that the
contracting is going as they wish
to make sure that the financing is
performing as they
had intended or if they want to now seek
some restructuring of how to do that and
then finally uh to make sure that the uh
that the performance
um
of the equipment and of the management
strategies the distributed generation
and so on are doing their job properly
and in that vein the free team offers a
multi-dimensional
team that can come in and help on all
three funds legal financial
and energy slash technology it is a
small fee that is
uh if it's at the choice of the
participant but it can be included in
the proceeds of the financing and uh
and paid off that way or there can be a
separate uh
consultancy that's set up for that
purpose um so far folks like to just
put it in the
in the proceeds of the finance
great thanks for that uh so that is all
the time we have uh for today uh i'd
like to thank bruce burt john adam and
alison for a really great presentation
uh we covered a lot of ground
and had a lot of great questions from
the audience so i'd like to thank
everyone for listening in and being part
of the presentation
i'd like to remind everyone that today's
talk will be made available online
through the yale center for business and
the environment website and our itunes u
page
we hope you'll join us for the next
blueprint for efficiency webinar in a
week's time it'll be co-hosted with the
council for development finance
authorities the cdfa
and we'll be looking at accessing
creative revenue sources for energy
efficiency
this is michael puckett from the gale
center for business and the environment
saying so long from new haven
connecticut